hi everyone today we are going to review
the five life changing books you must
read in this year 2022 each book focuses
on a particular skill which makes people
successful in their life they contain
decades of knowledge and it's worth
every second you spend on these books so
without further ado let's get started at
number one deep work by karl newport
deep work is on the importance of
focused work in order to succeed in an
increasingly distracted world the crux
of the book is that there are two kinds
of work we do one is shallow work deep
work shallow work is easy and ubiquitous
any work which needs a little bit of
time and focus like replying to emails
social media presence etc these works
are easy to replace and not valued much
in society and deep work is the ability
to focus without distraction on a
cognitively demanding task cultivating
deep work ethic will help you focus for
an extended period of time in producing
better outcomes and less time it's
demanding and helps people provide
valuable things to society that are hard
to replicate or replace the book is
divided into two parts part one is about
why deep work matters and its scientific
backing part two is how to achieve deep
work to increase productivity so if your
time and energy are being pulled in a
million different directions and you're
feeling overwhelmed this is a must read
book for you
at number 2 we have never split the
difference by chris foss
the author worked in the fbi as a
hostage negotiator which brought him
face to face with various criminals
including bank robbers and terrorists
with his vast experience he breaks down
everything into 9 effective principles
that you can use to become more
persuasive in both your professional and
personal life you might think
negotiation skill is not necessary for
you however life is a series of
negotiations and you negotiate all day
every day from the time you wake up to
the time you go to sleep
you should be prepared for buying a
house negotiating a salary client
interactions negotiating rent or
deliberating with your partner this is a
great book with direct applications to
day-to-day interactions with other
people including your family it helps
you sit through conflicts and tensions
and figure out better solutions that
result in better outcomes for you
in the end this is a book about not just
being good at negotiation but being
great in life never spread the
difference is deep wisdom conveyed with
great humor storytelling and insight
read it to be a more effective human
next on our list is the science of
storytelling by will storm stories are
what makes us human and in this book
will star talks about the themes and
characteristics that we need to use to
become better storytellers storytelling
is an integral part of human survival
and understanding how to put up a story
to trigger emotional elements of mind to
keep a viewer intrigued is what this
book digs deep into the book is divided
into four chapters designed to look at
the story through its various levels the
chapters are one creating a world
two the flawed self three the dramatic
questions and four plots endings and
meanings
though writers and would-be writers are
a primary audience for this book its
appeal is wider than that
somewhat profoundly it throws new light
on the story of our own lives as well so
if you are interested in learning the
art of storytelling we highly recommend
this book because it's written in a
concise and inspiring way and it
provides a lot of value at the fourth
spot we have the book to help you
improve your finances the psychology of
money by morgan hauser what's the best
way to manage your money that's a
question that everyone has an answer for
but the right question is what's the
best way for you and in comes the book
the psychology of money most books when
they analyze investment or financial
management focus solely on the technical
part of it but this book focuses on the
human psychology element of investing
and building up wealth over time through
the lens of history and personal tales
the author teaches us the most profound
insights on the psychology of money but
it means to us how we spend and save and
invest how we connect who we are today
and who we might be tomorrow morgan
teaches you how to have a better
relationship with money and to make
smarter financial decisions on top of it
all the book is a quick read with the
big payoff the last one on our list is
one of ray dalio's masterpieces
principles if you are a person
struggling with decision making this
book is for you you might have come
across many leadership and development
books but this book would hit you
differently with its practical resources
and mostly good narration this book lets
you take away of important principles
for your life like systemizing your
decision making being radically
open-minded how to handle your
weaknesses a five-step process to
ultimate success and learning how to
synthesize well through this book ray
dalio explains how to solve a problem to
get a token he calls principle which
enables him not to repeat the same
mistake again as said by ray dalio the
author principles are fundamental truths
that serve as the foundations for
behavior that get you what you want out
of life this book should go to your must
read list if you want to be a successful
entrepreneur or if you are a striving
employee who's dreaming of reaching
greater heights or even anyone who'd
like to learn and adapt new principles
in their life for a better future that
brings us to the end of the video thanks
for watching we hope you enjoyed this
video please comment down below the name
of the book you want to read first we
want to know and stay tuned for more
from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here